I'm Freddie Prinze jr. and I am voicing
the iron bull the iron bull is an
interesting guy he he looks one way and
acts another he's he's very very
complicated he's the opposite of any
Qunari you've ever sort of experienced
in the franchise he is not solemn he is
not flat he is much more emotional than
than your normal qunari and he's really
only afraid of one thing which is demons
because they possess people and make you
act weird and it freaks him out he's
still willing to kill them and and and
hack and slash them until they're no
more but he definitely is he's
definitely afraid he doesn't have a
moral code the way we as mere mortals -
I think he looks at most species as
survivalists and they're willing to do
whatever is necessary to survive it's
not good or bad just don't get in his
way or you're gonna get ripped up he's
very much on sort of this the the
defrocked samurai path sort of the the
Ronin Warrior I'm gonna do my own thing
unless I find a cause worth fighting for
and I'll fight for that for as long as I
see fit and I'll have sex with everyone
and move on my way he's the James Bond
of qunari I spent a year or two working
for Fisher's bleeders but their captain
was crap figured I could do better I
snapped his sword in half and we talked
things out over drinks I did James Vega
for Mass Effect 3 and he was a beta
personality I will follow orders I will
do as you say
and the wool is don't give them an order
don't give them an order if you're an
alpha personality he'll get along with
you well if you complimented me yes I am
great I am fantastic but I don't care
and that's kind of that's sort of who he
is he's a very sort of up and down kind
of kind of guy we've hunted we once
fought through caves to find some old
magical crap even when giant baiting
once I've never had the passion for the
movies and television that I've had for
video games so it's funny the first one
I ever did was Mass Effect the first
time I got to voice a video game and I
feel like gamers know how the characters
should act I feel like sometimes you
play games and you just know the guy
doesn't play you know I'm not gonna blow
anybody up but you know who you are
and you shouldn't be doing it anybody
mind if I take some souvenirs maybe just
a couple of those pruned helmets right
you two just work whatever that is out
of your system like poison weird-ass
poison and the thing that mass effected
and a lot of Bioware games do is they
really play into the psychology of it
and they it's not so much about
empowering the gamer as empowering
everyone in the game the fact that you
could have relationships you know
whether they were sexual and adult and
nature or whether they were just two
friends and soldiers looking out for one
of one another and knowing that they
both gone through a lot of crap it was a
big deal and I think that's why people
sort of connected to the Shepherd
character so much more like you play
Super Mario Brothers but you're not
Mario right you push a button any jumps
and he says look at me but you're never
him right you're Shepard like everything
about him is your choice so that's I
think why the game was so special and
that's why the Dragon Age games work
because they're give not just you power
to make the character your own it goes
way deeper than that it's about
relationships and who do you trust and
what type of characters do you like to
bring into battle with you who's gonna
help you bottleneck these mages who's
gonna help you stay out of line of sight
that we're talking Dragon Age now line
of sight means if the mage can see you
you're frigging dead so have a wall
between you have a corner and say
your henchmen to go help you out and
that's a good that's a good trick to get
you through all the pros are like yeah
whatever we know that but there's no
people to we're gonna do that again
because it's sound I spent to you or to
working for fissures bleeders but their
captain was crap figured I could do
better the best folks in the bleed has
agreed with me and the greedy they
agreed it that's plural for agreed